we have two of our favorite Marvel
topics today Deadpool and the Avengers
what's up everyone it's Warren and there
are a lot of reports going around right
now about Deadpool entering the MCU and
Avengers 5 we have reports saying that
Deadpool can make an appearance as early
on as phase 4 in the MCU and then
eventually go on to be in the next
Avengers film this is obviously super
exciting news about the future of the
MCU so I'll go ahead and break down all
the reports and rumors in this video
about Deadpool
and Avengers 5 also if you'd like a
chance to win an Xbox one or ps4 be sure
to subscribe to my channel to enter my
giveaway and stick around till the end
of the video to hear more about it so as
with all unofficial reports and rumors
you should take this with a grain of
salt but there are reports going around
that Deadpool is going to be making his
MCU debut in Avengers 5 now we don't
really know too much about the next
Avengers film but we do know that it is
going to be happening in an interview
with Marvel Studios President Kevin
Feige directly after the Marvel phase 4
reveal at San Diego comic-con he was
asked about the new Avengers that were
coming and if he knew who they were and
he replied with yes and he said that
they're going to be very different than
before well Deadpool is certainly a very
very different addition to the Avengers
team than we've seen before now we all
miss Tony Stark and are sad that he's
not going to be in the MCU moving
forward and something that we're all
going to miss from him is his sarcasm
and his sass well Deadpool can
definitely bring some sarcasm and some
sass to the Avengers team and again in
an interview directly after the face for
reveal at San Diego Comic Con Kevin
Feige did address Deadpool joining the
MCU at San Diego Comic Con on stage
Kevin Feige mentioned that the mutants
were coming and in the interview after
he said that Deadpool is a mutant and he
considers him part of that grouping
therefore Deadpool is coming to the MCU
and not to mention Ryan Reynolds
recently teased his MCU debut as
Deadpool on Instagram and now according
to a report from the account timbo who
has recently been releasing phase 5 info
Deadpool is going to be in the black
widow post credits scene the account
says that it's sources say the in credit
scene for Black Widow will feature
taskmaster meeting Deadpool in a bar now
this actually makes a lot of
black widow is going to be a movie that
is featuring a lot of assassins and
mercenaries taskmaster is a mercenary
and Deadpool is a mercenary so the two
of them linking up in the post-credits
scene for Black Widow actually makes a
lot of sense not only is this account
reporting that Deadpool is going to be
in the post-credits scene of the Black
Widow film it's also reporting that
Deadpool is going to be in the next
Avengers film stating that Ryan Reynolds
has recently signed a new deal with
Marvel / Disney now this also makes a
lot of sense because Disney and Marvel
now owned the rights to use Deadpool in
the MCU so it would make sense that
Disney and Marvel would draft up a new
contract for Ryan Reynolds to play
Deadpool moving forward in the MCU since
the Disney Foxx deal is now complete now
again not much is really known about the
next Avengers film besides the fact that
Kevin Feige said that it will be very
different and obviously Deadpool would
make it very different indeed and
considering the massive success that
Deadpool has had with Fox it makes sense
that Disney would want to incorporate
Deadpool into the MCU soon and again
Kevin Feige has teased Deadpool and an
Avengers film coming soon and Ryan
Reynolds has teased Deadpool coming to
the MCU in phase 5 that combined with
these rumors and reports that Deadpool
is going to be in the post-credits scene
of Black Widow and the next Avengers
film all line up and make perfect sense
this is what we have all been waiting
for the Fox characters to jump over into
the MCU and it seems like it could be
happening really really soon Deadpool
joining the Avengers is going to be a
huge event so let me know how excited
you are to finally see this happen leave
your comments down below and don't
forget to comment with your favorite
superhero or villain like this video and
be subscribed to my channel so you can
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or a ps4 I'll be picking a
winner when I hit 500,000 subscribers I
also do giveaways on my Twitter and
Instagram as well so be sure to follow
me on there and as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof woof